le sentier de grande randonnée de
l'iPhone les paysages vallonnés de
l'ouest de l'Allemagne nous abordons la
deuxième partie de ce périple de 313 km
au pays des volcans éteints depuis
Gerolstein nous traverserons Dawn
menderscheide évite les tapultime de ce
voyage dans l'iPhone 13 la plus vieille
ville d'Allemagne
cette contrée de l'iPhone est une région
parsemée d'anciens volcans dans ce
massif de l'ouest de l'Allemagne
bouillonnait il n'y a pas si longtemps
une infernale fournaise
un passé agité mais à l'origine d'un
trésor de la nature la roche volcanique
et le berceau du eau minérale saine et
vivifiante naturellement gazeuse
petite station climatique baignée par
laquille que nous avons donné
rendez-vous à Oliver Blum il va nous
accompagner lors de cette première étape
de notre randonnée
nous faisons le plein avant d'entamer la
balade
veut nous emmener sur le plus haut
sommet du pays de Gerolstein le DIDS
online qui culmine à plus de 600 mètres
depuis la petite tour panoramique la vue
s'étend sur des kilomètres sur le massif
de l'iPhone
l'un des châteaux forts de l'iPhone les
mieux conservés c'est aussi le lieu de
travail de l'hiver il est maître
boulanger et a remis en service un
magnifique four à bois traditionnel
typique de cette région d'Allemagne
mais qui dit tradition ne dit pas
forcément méthode archaïque dans le
fournil Oliver travaille avec des
instruments bien de son temps c'est
indispensable pour répondre à la demande
d'une clientèle de plus en plus
nombreuse autant dire qu'Oliver a plus
que du pain sur la planche
le geste du boulanger est sûr les
ingrédients authentiques
la levée de la pâte se fait en deux
temps puis Oliver en fourne les pâtons
les plus anciennes parties du château
datent de 1280 mais l'édifice repose
sans aucun doute sur des fondations
datant de l'époque romaine contrairement
à la plupart des châteaux de l'iPhone le
château de lisingen n'a jamais été
détruit et est resté relativement
préservé des dommages du temps
le visiteur fait un véritable voyage
dans le temps dans ses salles presque
intactes la magie médiévale opère
au bout de deux heures de cuisson les
miches sont bien dorées
Oliver vérifie que le pain est cuit à
cœur
le pain de l'hiver est un pain de
campagne rustique à l'amidence égouteuse
un pain typique de l'iPhone terrien et
solide
nous avons à présent rendez-vous avec
Dirks et qui va nous faire entrer dans
le Saint des Saints la source de l'eau
minérale de Gerolstein birkens et
chimiste pour geerelsteiner la Société
des Eaux minérales de geerolstein
un gisement aquifère sous haute
surveillance Dirk kreims procède
régulièrement à des contrôles de qualité
draconien lentement filtré à travers la
terre volcanique de l'iPhone enrichit en
minéraux par la roche dolomitique l'eau
minérale de gearstein s'accumule goutte
après goutte à 200 mètres sous terre au
moment du pompage elle est immédiatement
acheminée vers la station
d'embouteillage sans étapes
intermédiaire qui pourrait la dénaturer
elle revoit le jour pur et intacte dans
une bouteille à son arrivée l'eau est
séparée de son gaz carbonique
précieusement conservé puis elle est
déférisée pour la préserver de
l'oxydation le gaz est ensuite
réintroduit dans les mêmes proportions
qu'à l'émergence la société Gerolsteiner
brownen et leader sur le marché des eaux
minérales allemandes un succès qui
s'exporte l'eau minéral de Gerolstein
est distribué dans plus de 40 pays
mais retournons à présent au grand air à
une dizaine de kilomètres de Gerolstein
s'élève le nerrotor coop le vestige d'un
volcan après des décennies
d'exploitation forestière la nature
reprend peu à peu ses droits l'homme y
est le bienvenu mes doigts se garder
d'intervenir les sols sont jauchées
d'arbres morts la végétation pousse à
son propre rythme c'est ainsi que
naissent les forêts vierges de demain
nous nous dirigeons Verdun en gravissant
les 12 pentes du mont kalenberg
Dawn est une petite ville thermale
nichée au creux de la vallée de la
lisière
nous y retrouvons Harim kughel et Céline
rein et que deux nouveaux compagnons de
route pour une nouvelle étape qui nous
emmènera jusqu'à mundersheid
les randonneurs chevronnés veulent nous
faire découvrir quelques-unes des plus
grandes merveilles naturelles de
l'iPhone volcanique
le temps est magnifique cette balade
promet d'être des plus agréables
les voici les mares les lacs de cratères
nés de la rencontre orageuse de l'eau et
du magma en fusion il y a 10 000 ans de
cela le marc de gomunt est un petit lac
bleu nuit presque noir fréquenté en été
par les baigneurs et canneurs l'eau est
plutôt froide mais nous ne boudons pas
notre plaisir
rive boisé eau profondes et
scintillantes l'atmosphère est
enchanteresse presque irréel
nous prenons un peu de hauteur sur la
tour donc du nom du fondateur de
l'association de l'iPhone qui œuvre pour
le développement et le rayonnement de
cette région d'Allemagne les alentours
de Dawn compte deux autres de ses
curiosités géologiques le marc devient
unefeld est celui de schalkenberen très
proche l'un de l'autre
ici les habitants les surnomme les yeux
bleus de l'iPhone pour harrim et Céline
c'est une source d'émerveillement sans
cesse renouvelée
la vallée de la lisère est sans doute
l'un des plus beaux paysages que
traverse le sentier
Céline et Harim continuent leur chemin
nous nous décidons de faire un petit
détour nous avons entendu parler d'un
élevage de bœuf bio particulièrement
réputé situé à strônes et puis une
petite étape gourmande ça ne se refuse
pas
Norbert automne élève des beux de la
fameuse race limousine réputée pour sa
rusticité sa robustesse et la saveur
unique de sa viande son cheptel compte
une quarantaine de têtes pour Norbert
automne il est important que ses bêtes
soient élevées humainement dans de
bonnes conditions sans compter que le
stress affecte la qualité finale de la
viande
le jambon de bœuf fumé c'est une des
spécialités de Norbert après avoir
maturé quelques jours les morceaux de
viande sont placés dans un fumoir à
chaud durée du fumage environ 3 semaines
la ferme vend directement ses produits
de charcuterie c'est Martin l'épouse de
Norbert qui tient la boutique
le jambon de bœuf fumé de Norbert
automne s'apprécitel quel en tranches
très fines
prochaine destination mandership et ses
deux châteaux forts
nous retrouvons Céline et Harim qui
achève ici leur balade le long du
sentier de l'iPhone devant l'hôtel de
ville
séparé par la liseur les ruines de
lobberburg et du leaderburg semblent se
défier magnifique exemple d'architecture
militaire médiévale il témoigne de la
lutte pour le pouvoir dans l'iPhone au
Moyen-Âge
lobberbourg appartenait à l'électorat de
Trêves et le Nidor était possession
luxembourgeoise
à présent direction l'est dans la forêt
de immoraux
nous croisons la route de Monica
borscheid et de sylviae Cell de
randonneuses originaires de la rour
lifel et leur domaine de randonnée de
prédilection aujourd'hui elle se rendent
au monastère de émeraude
fondée au 12e siècle l'abbaye
cistercienne Notre-Dame de Wimereux est
un important lieu de pèlerinage un des
nombreux chemins de Saint-Jacques de
Compostelle passe à proximité
l'abbaye est un édifice aux lignes
épurées tout en sobriété en accord avec
les valeurs cisterciennes
aujourd'hui 13 mois de cisterciens
vivent des travails ou monastères la
prière commune est l'Office qu'il
réunissent cette fois par jour aura
élabora pris et travail un précepte que
le Père Stéphane applique tous les jours
le monastère a une longue tradition
d'exploitation agricole et d'élevage il
possède d’ailleurs un petit étang à
truite dont le pisciculteur Axel Borre à
la charge
de quoi réjouir les clients du
restaurant de l'Abbaye
en effet bien que remplissant une
fonction essentiellement monastique
l'abbaye n'est pas un lieu fermé mais
ouvert sur le monde la spiritualité et
la sérénité qui se dégage de ces lieux
doit être partagé par le plus grand
nombre l'hospitalité est ainsi une
valeur que les moines ont à cœur de
préserver
Wolfgang hilgert et le chef du
restaurant au menu aujourd'hui de la
truite bien sûr pour commencer le chef
nappe le poisson d'une marinade à base
de sauce wasters et de jus de citron
sont l'aliment incontournables de cette
région de l'iPhone
en accompagnement de la truite Wolfgang
hilgart se prépare un deux peu courts
une sorte de gâteau de pommes de terre
râpées avec de l'oignon des œufs du
jambon et de la mie de pain autrefois le
2 peut court était un plat conservé
surtout pour les fêtes et les grandes
occasions
pendant que le gâteau cuit au four le
chef fait griller la truite dans du
beurre avec quelques gousses d'ail bien
parfumées
truite dans son manteau d'amande
accompagnée d'un gâteau de pommes de
terre un plat dont le succès ne s'est
jamais démenti
l'abbaye de émeraude a été fondée par
Bernard de Clairvaux maître spirituel de
l'ordre des cisterciens en quelques
années les moines en ont fait l'un des
centres religieux les plus importants de
l'iPhone
pour le Père Stéphane qui vit au
monastère depuis plus de 40 ans la
beauté de la nature environnante la
quiétude des lieux sont une source de
recueillement tout aussi importante que
l'enceinte du monastère
en écoutant le Père Stéphane on ne peut
s'empêcher de penser que pour beaucoup
d'entre nous ce retour à soi et l'un des
moteurs essentiels de la marche
aujourd'hui
il est temps de reprendre notre bâton de
pèlerin prochaine arrêt drive non loin
de vitrich
nous arrivons dans un jardin plutôt
extraordinaire à la faune pour le moins
original un élégant chalet nous
accueille en bordure d'une forêt de
sapin nous voici au valt hôtel Sonora le
restaurant du chef étoilé elmoutil
caisse de la petite pension familiale
elle monte a fait un établissement
prestigieux et est parvenu à force de
travail d'obstination à se hisser parmi
les plus grands c'est aussi un chef
respecté de ses employés avec lesquels
il tient à s'entretenir tous les jours
Helmut t-il à la préparation d'un riz de
veau il commence par faire rôtir
quelques champignons
et bras droit Thomas shanz nous parle de
son métier avec passion
une jolie mousse de persil viendra
rehausser le plat d'un verre lumineux
un cône de spaghettis savamment enroulé
trouve également sa place sur l'assiette
et pour terminer elle motive Guess
ajoute encore une petite cuillère de
sauce aux truffes
l'alliance de deux virtuoses de la
cuisine a consommé sans modération
nous reprenons notre route sur le
sentier de l'iPhone prochaine
destination cordel Dagmar laushuz et
Petra Friedrich nous accompagne pour un
bout de chemin dans un écrin de verdure
se dresse le château de Ramstein datant
du premier millénaire du logis
seigneurial qui s'élevait autrefois sur
une hauteur de 25 mètres il ne reste
plus que quelques murs
c'est aujourd'hui une curiosité très
prisée des visiteurs
le doux paysage de la vallée de laquille
nous accueille à présent un peu plus
haut le sentier de l'iPhone continue en
direction du sud dans les vergers les
pommiers sont chargés de fruits bien mûr
la famille reichhard cultive ici une
variété de petites pommes acides d'un
rouge éclatant idéal pour la fabrication
du Cid ces jours de récolte à l'aide
d'une grande perche les pommes sont
gaulées une technique que Mathias serai
cher te maîtrise à la perfection
les pommes acides diffèrent des pommes
de table de par leur concentration en
tanins et leur acidité elle que rail
short a planté ses pommiers avec son
mari et les a vu grandir
le Fitz c'est le nom qu'on donne aussi
dans l'aifel Avenches Billy la cidrerie
de Marc Conrad travaille avec les
exploitants locaux qui lui apportent
directement leur production juste après
la récolte
les fruits sont triés lavés et broyés
afin d'en extraire le jus lorsque la
saison du cidre basse en plein se sont
près de 400 tonnes de pommes qui sont
transformés ici 100 kg de pommes donne
environ 70 litres de jus
le mou est ensuite placé dans des cuves
où il va fermenter pendant 6 à 10
semaines
le contrôle de la fermentation est fait
par soutirage successifs
le résultat semble aller à la hauteur
sous le soleil d'hiver les champs de
colza sont si lumineux que Dagmar et
pétrin ont pu s'empêcher d'aller les
voir de plus près
nous sommes presque arrivé à 13 baigné
par la Moselle
mais avant d'aller rendre visite à la
doyenne des villes allemandes nous
faisons une petite halte à falcel au
cLOSTER Schenk un restaurant
traditionnel
le chef Christian Zener s'occupe d'un
magnifique cendre pêché dans la Moselle
il pratique de petites entailles
régulières sur la peau du poisson pour
éviter qu'il ne se replie sur lui-même
lors de la cuisson
Le Cendre est un poisson qui se marie à
merveille avec la choucroute elle est
brièvement revenue dans du saindoux puis
mouillé d'une bonne rasade de riesling
dans un morceau de tissu fin Christian
Zener confectionne un petit sac dans
lequel il dispose des grains de poivre
des baies de genièvre et du laurier il
infusera doucement dans la préparation
il coupe ensuite des pommes de terre
cuites et du boudin de Trèves en petits
morceaux qui l'enroule dans une feuille
de brick
et pour lier la choucroute rien de mieux
qu'un peu de pomme de terre râpée
les filets de poisson sont passés dans
la farine et poêlée
les rouleaux de pommes de terre et de
boudin sont plongés dans un bain d'huile
la cuisson ne prend que quelques minutes
Christian Zener n'a pas son pareil pour
réinventer les grands classiques
sur la terrasse du restaurant
l'atmosphère est toute méditerranéenne
Christian Zener et son ami Christiana ne
peuvent s'accorder que peu de temps
libre mais il ne renoncerait pour rien
au monde au plaisir d'une petite balade
dans les sous-bois
la ville est un concentré de culture et
d'histoire d'abord siège du pouvoir
impérial romain puis l'un des grands
centres du christianisme primitif et
enfin une ville médiévale dynamique elle
a su garder de précieuses marques
architecturales à l'image de la
remarquable cathédrale Saint-Pierre
devant la porte à nigra nous terminons
notre voyage le long d'un des plus beaux
sentiers d'Allemagne le sentier de
grande randonnée de l'iPhone